12000 c'est le nombre de professionnels
qui participent au Marché du Film à
Cannes les professionnels du cinéma du
monde entier s'y retrouve pour acheter
ou vendre des films Quentin Dupuis est
un jeune réalisateur de 24 ans
originaire de plaisir il vient à Cannes
pour la troisième année consécutive et
contrairement aux années précédentes il
n'a pas de films à montrer mais des
projets a financé
Quentin Dupuy est un passionné de cinéma
depuis qu'il est enfant un rêve qu'il a
concrétisé en faisant un BTS audiovisuel
trois années de suite qu'il vient au
Festival de Cannes dans sa mallette un
ordinateur avec ces dernières
réalisations depuis son dernier séjour
sur la Croisette Quentin n'a pas Chaumet
il a réalisé un spot contre la
banalisation de l'homophobie qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce t-shirt
mais attends ça fait trop gay
plusieurs pilotes de web série je pense
qu'il faut que je connaisse un peu mieux
le milieu avant de vous manager et
l'humilité vous connaissez et un clip
pour un groupe de rock alternatif
Cannes pour lui c'est THE place to be
toute la ville vie cinéma pendant 15
jours et c'est la beauté la beauté du
festival c'est à dire que au-delà du
stress et des paillettes des tapis rouge
vraiment tous les films qu'on va voir
tout ce vent s'achète ce produit ici
enfin pas tous mais c'est un des plus
gros marchés de l'année un des plus gros
festivals de l'année donc il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui se font
donc c'est ça le
le grand avantage
et du coup quand tu as enchaîne les
rencontres ce jour-là il a rendez-vous
au pavillon américain près du Palais des
Festivals d'années en année Quentin le
CS d'étoffer son carnet d'adresses ce
producteur réalisateur Peter mussoli par
exemple
est devenu l'un de ses amis l'Amérique
un idéal pour Quentin c'est très
business et très d'autobus c'est très
quel est ton projet comment tu veux le
développer qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
et voilà c'est ce que ce qui est
vraiment très intéressant ils sont très
ouverts quand ils aiment ils aiment
quand ils aiment pas ils aiment pas
l'ont passé Quentin avait présenté
intact au Short Film Corner l'espace
dédié au court-métrage l'histoire de
deux survivants face à une menace de
zombie Peter mussoli a été séduit par ce
film et il a lancé un défi à Quentin on
est bien ici non
sentir vivant ça te permet depuis
combien de temps
je lui ai dit et Quentin et si on en
faisait un long métrage
j'y vois le potentiel d'un alien quelque
chose dans l'esprit des premiers films
de Ridley Scott ou Dabis de James
Cameron quelque chose de vraiment bien
et d'intéressant mais sans besoin d'un
énorme budget du coup je lui ai dit
allez faisons un film tu as un mois pour
l'écrire
un scénario est né un road movie en
Afrique avec deux personnages qui
tombent de survivre dans un monde peuplé
de zombie Quentin est donc maintenant à
la recherche de partenaires pour
financer son long-métrage
entre 500
000 et 1 million de dollars pour
l'instant ce qui peut paraître énorme
mais ce qui est relativement petit pour
le monde du cinéma ça reste un film
indépendant ça reste un petit budget et
voilà
on va voir ce qui va se passer c'est de
monter de monter ce projet le mieux
possible Cannes c'est la terre des
cinéphiles et une vitrine médiatique
quand en profite donc pour prendre des
contacts et essayer de convaincre des
producteurs et des distributeurs de
l'aider à boucler son budget et ainsi
réaliser son rêve faire son premier
long-métrage